[Musique]
les gens qui voient le travers pense que
les bancs verts qu'on voit sur les
trottoirs sont faits pour les impôts ou
les ventes tripotent
c'est une absurdité car à la vérité il
sent la scène en toi pour accueillir
quelques temps les amours débutants
[Musique]
les amoureux qui se décote sur les bancs
publics en public bancs publics en se
foutant pas mal de gars obliques mais
pas sans honnête les amoureux qui se
décollent sur les ponts bibliques en
public en public en disant des je t'aime
pathétiques antiques
il se tiennent par la main par le du
lendemain du papier bleu d'azur le
revêtiront les murs de leur chambre à
coucher
dans un bien-être sur un et choisissent
les prénoms de leur premier bébé leur
premier les amoureux qui se décollent
sur les bancs publics en public
en se foutant pas mal de regards
obliques regardez 300 années les amas se
quittent sur les pauvre en public
en disant des jeunes pathétiques une
petite gueule bien sympathique quand la
Sainte Famille machin croise sur son
chemin de de ces malapris elle leur
décoche arguments des propos venus
n'empêche que toute la famille le père
la mère la fille le fils Saint-Esprit
voudrait bien de temps en temps pouvoir
se conduire comme lui comme les amoureux
qui se décollent sur les bancs
[Musique]
sympathique quand les mois auront passé
quand seront apaisés leurs beaux rêves
[Musique]
se couvrira le gros nuage
il s'apercevront tes murs c'est au
hasard des rues sur un de ces femmes
bancs ils ont vécu le meilleur morceau
de leur amour leur amour
[Musique]
les amoureux qui se décollent-ils